reconnaître se passer c'est aussi et
surtout poursuivre l'oeuvre de justice
en nous engageant à ce qu'aucune
personne soupçonnée de crimes de
génocide ne puisse échapper au travail
des juges reconnaître se passer notre
responsabilité
est un geste sans contrée par
exigence
envers nous-mêmes et pour nous mêmes
ted
envers les victimes après tant de
silence passé
donc
envers les vivants nous pouvons celle
accepte encore apaiser la douleur
le parcours de reconnaissance à travers
nos dettes
nos dons nous offre l'espoir de sortir
de cette nuit et de cheminer à nouveau
ensemble
sur ce chemin
seuls ceux qui ont traversé les nuits
peut-être par deux
nous faire le compte alors
de nous pardonner